the internet is ablaze with what most
conservatives are calling a hellish
techno dystopia
this care of the kingdom of saudi arabia
which has proposed building a 1 640 foot
high 106 mile long city for nine million
people
built into a mirrored wall
for too long humanity has existed within
dysfunctional and polluted cities that
ignore nature
now a revolution in civilization is
taking place
imagine a traditional city and
consolidating its footprint
designing to protect and enhance nature
the line will be home to nine million
residents and will be built with a
footprint of just 34 square kilometers
and we are designing it to provide a
healthier more sustainable quality of
life
the lions communities are organized in
three dimensions
residents have access to all their daily
needs within five-minute walk
neighborhoods
and the line's infrastructure makes it
possible to travel end-to-end in 20
minutes with no need for cars resulting
in zero carbon emissions the line is 500
meters tall
200 meters wide
170 kilometers long
and housed within an elegant mirror
glass facade the line
the city that delivers new wonders for
the world
i love it
i totally love it it is the answer to so
many of our problems
conservatives hate this stuff because
it's extremely ugly and inhuman
but libs love it libs are the ones who
are attracted to all this weirdo
futuristic stuff
which means that saudi arabia has
figured out a way to cram all the libs
into a giant self-sustaining wall that
they basically never leave and convince
them that it's really cool and
progressive and good for the environment
here is the entire pitch you say hey
libs great news
yeah yeah we figured out how to save the
planet uh-huh yeah we solved climate
change yep it's great we just need you
to climb inside this giant wall prison
uh-huh just get on in there yep and then
that's it great job we did it
and then they just stay there
and then
we get our normal society back
and by the way lest you forget
it's a wall
it's a wall
if the saudis give us the technology and
we can build this thing along our
southern border right along the rio
grande then muhammad bin salman deserves
a nobel prize i am all in
and this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from charles davis
who says i got to watch fouchy unmasked
a few days ago excellent series michael
thank you so much what a great comment
really important comment now because the
republicans are finally threatening to
investigate dr fauci if they retake the
congress fauci is running away there is
pretty much a fouchy-shaped hole in the
nih he is so eager to run away from
those investigations make sure you arm
yourself with the facts by watching
fauci unmasked over at daily wire plus
then once you know everything you can
talk to your friends about it when i
want to talk to my friends you know what
i love puretalk right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code knowles
podcast you're getting pinched right now
everything that you buy is getting more
expensive with one exception
your cell phone plan if you switch to
pure talk what are you spending on your
cell phone bill probably
60 70
i don't know 80 or 90 bucks a month you
can cut that by two-thirds if you switch
to puretalk right now puretalk gives you
talk text plenty of data for just 30 per
month no price increase there no byte
inflation affecting that i am a pure
talk customer i love pure talk it's
incredibly reliable i use puretalk a lot
for my job i use puretalk for my
personal life the 5g coverage is great
plus they make the switch from your
current provider incredibly easy won't
take you more than 10 minutes which is
amazing well worth the savings 10
minutes definitely well worth saving 60
bucks a month right now our listeners by
the way in addition to that are saving
50 off their first month when they use
promo code noel's podcast at
puretalk.com hard to depend on the
government hard to depend on this crazy
economy you can depend on pure talk
puretalk.com select a plan enter promo
code noel's podcast say 50 off your
first month switch over in less than 10
minutes puretalk.com promo code
k-n-o-w-l-e-s-p-o-d-c-a-s-t
all one word
speaking of
difficult neighborhoods to live in
how's that for a transition
portland residents portland residents
one of the most liberal cities in a very
liberal state in america
they are
finally realizing how terrible it is to
live under those disastrous policies in
those terrible neighborhoods and the
portland residents are speaking out
i'm living in a nightmare neighborhood
it's really scary for years these
neighbors have been watching the city's
homeless crisis spread across parts of
southeast portland now it's right
outside their front door
i want to cry i just want my house back
christina hartnett lives on 80th and
powell where a majority of the campers
stay my lawn
is now becoming a public bathroom she
fears leaving her house just to go to
work and it is scary when you have grown
men meth raging
in your driveway
the last thing i feel safe doing is
going out and saying hey can i can you
please move so i can go to work calling
the police and city is an everyday chore
with little reward
so far no one has come to help us i feel
like nobody hears us
nobody cares about us this mother didn't
want to be identified on camera afraid
of retaliation from those living on the
streets she rarely lets her children
outside to play
it's very sad
because my they're just kids so they
want to play
that is very sad this is really sad we
have so many of our public political
debates at this level of ideology
at the level of well this is my utopian
vision for the future this is my utopian
vision this is how society would work if
i were the king no this is how it worked
if i were the king you see kind of these
utopian visions coming out of saudi
arabia right now that's where our
political debates tend to live
but
where the political debates really
should live and for the vast majority of
people who don't have their
faces buried in the political headlines
all the time where it really does live
is on hey
is do i have a good neighborhood for my
kids hey can i go outside and not be
afraid for my life
hey can i just kind of have a nice
day-to-day existence without having to
worry about crazy meth heads or
criminals coming and attacking my kids
or stealing my stuff or defecating on my
lawn
that's
that's the first kind of political
problem you've got to solve before we
get to all of our wonderful pie in the
sky
dreams and it's not just republicans who
think that way and it's not just
democrats who think that way
at the elected level frankly no one no
one thinks in those basic terms about
things that actually matter to people
this is why trump was such a breath of
fresh air in 2016. when he i remember
vividly when he was on the campaign
trail and he was asked what are you
going to do if you're president he said
i want to give people good neighborhoods
and a good place to live and everyone
forget about the left even everyone on
the right attacked him for it
because they all got their kind of
egghead libertarian ideologue glasses
and and and bow ties on and they said
well actually that's not the role of the
federal government to provide good
neighborhoods for people and actually no
but the only thing you can do is cut the
marginal tax rate on blah blah blah blah
blah and i think the vast majority of
people heard trump say that and said oh
yeah that sounds good i want a good
neighborhood i want a good community
i want a good way of life okay and i
want my president with whatever power
he's got to try to improve life at a
very basic level for people okay at the
level of how do we live day by day
those people in that video
living in portland those are not
rock-ribbed right-wing republicans i
imagine that inasmuch as those people
have any political affiliations they're
all democrats
i just just statistically that's that's
what we're looking at in portland
and they know that these policies
are terrible
it's not just portland the new york
mayor eric adams has been whining for
two weeks now about how texas is bussing
illegal aliens up to new york
illegal aliens illegal immigration the
policy that eric adams supports a total
dem policy
now new yorkers are seeing the
consequence of that they realize it's
terrible
the end and on crime too and on
homelessness too
the new yorkers most of whom are
democrats are realizing that those
policies are terrible muriel bowser down
in dc the super lib dem mayor of dc is
complaining that red red state governors
are shipping illegal aliens to dc
super lib policy they're just seeing the
consequences of it right now
it's the democrats realizing that that's
what joe biden is worried about
that's what the white house is worried
about they're not worried about angry
republicans or even republicans being
fired up and energized for the midterms
what they're really terrified of is that
they're losing the moderates and they're
losing the centrists and they're losing
a ton of democrats because
eventually reality reasserts itself and
you're seeing the consequences of defund
the police and you're seeing the
consequences of let the criminals off
the hook and you're seeing the
consequences of decriminalize all the
drugs and you're seeing the consequences
of destroy the economy and you're seeing
the consequences of flood the country
with illegal aliens
it takes a little while but eventually
you see the reality of that and even the
dems don't like it because even if they
might be
titillated by the pie in the sky
ideology eventually
when someone is defecating on your lawn
there's there is
pretty much no one who is so committed
to his or her ideology that he will
continue to support that
when you actually see the meth head
tweaking on your front step that's just
not going to work so the only thing they
can do is lie and try to redefine all
the terms we are now in a recession we
are officially in a recession the second
quarter gdp numbers have come out we've
got two consecutive quarters of negative
gdp growth the white house has asked
about this
this is just before the numbers come out
they're asked about their attempt to
redefine
recession
and what do they do
they redefine
redefining
if things are going so great though then
why is it the white house officials are
trying to redefine
recession no we're not redefining
recession if we all understand a
recession to be two consecutive quarters
of negative gdp growth in a row and then
you have white house officials come up
here to say no no that's not what a
recession is it's something else how is
that not redefining recession because
that's not the definition
that is not the definition
said in 2008 of course economists have a
technical definition
which is of a recession which is two
consecutive quarters
of negative growth
i can tell you this they said two
consecutive quarters of gdp growth is
not the technical definition of
recession
it is not why did he say that it is not
i can i can speak to i can speak to you
to what he said yesterday in front of
all of you which is the last thing that
you just repeated there are many factors
there are many factors economic factors
and indicators to consider
and
i will say that the textbook definition
of recession is not is not two negative
quarters of gdp
i will not i will not speak to la la la
la la kareem pear white house spokesman
i will not acknowledge what the national
economic council chairman said in 2008 i
will not i will ignore that i will only
speak to what he said yesterday because
oceania is at war with east asia oceania
has always been at war with east asia
that's their story and they're sticking
to it
peter ducey brings the receipts to the
white house
peter ducey
the reporter in in the white house press
pool he shows up to the briefing room
and he says we're in a recession right
or we're about to be officially in a
recession and karine jean-pierre says no
we're not in a recession he goes why are
you redefining recession she goes we're
not redefining recession recession is
not two consecutive quarters of negative
gdp growth and the person she cites is
brian deese who's the director of the
white house national economic council
brian dees has been going on tv going to
the white house saying that the actual
technical definition of a recession is
not two consecutive quarters of negative
gdp growth which was news to all of us
because if you ever took an economics
class if you ever opened up a dictionary
if you open up a dictionary today you
will find that the technical definition
of a recession is two consecutive
quarters of negative gdp growth but then
i had i was second guessing myself i was
being successfully gaslit by the white
house because i thought huh i don't know
i'm not an economist maybe i'm just
wrong about this
and then peter ducey says wait a second
in 2008
this same man
this very same director of the national
economic council brian deese said
verbatim the technical definition
economists have a technical definition
of recession which is two consecutive
quarters of negative gdp growth oh okay
i guess we're just being gaslit then
right and
because ducey brought the receipts
karine jean-pierre had nothing to say
and she her actual answer is i'm not
going to talk about that
i'm not going to acknowledge what he
said i'm not going to acknowledge the
dictionary i'm not going to acknowledge
the economics textbooks the definition
of a recession is whatever i want it to
be or whatever joe biden says it is
but that is not the case words do have
meaning
there is a a reality to the economy and
we are now officially in a recession
biden can keep lying about it all he
wants
just like the libs can say that a man is
actually a woman or the libs can say
that a baby's not a baby and the libs
are going to try to say that a recession
is not a recession but it is we are
officially in a recession and joe
biden's lies are not going to make it
any easier on your wallet speaking of
sketchy finances i got to give a shout
out to tyler cardin over at the blaze
my friend tyler
came across a pretty interesting
discovery
uh last night is when i saw it on
twitter
this comes from the new york daily news
december 23 1997 article by
greg b smith
it's referencing some pretty nice
manhattan real estate
talking about how this
the state department owned some real
estate a nice building on east 69th
street big old mansion that was the
official iranian residence and then
someone took it over and then the state
department was renting it out to people
listen to who the state department was
renting it out to
quote the state department began renting
the building
to jeffrey epstein a palm beach florida
finance financial advisor in 1992 for 15
000
per month by january 1996 epstein had
moved out he eventually decided to rent
to
fisher a lawyer who represented blah
blah blah blah blah
fischer began paying epstein twenty
thousand dollars a month a tidy five
thousand dollar a month profit for
epstein that the government didn't know
about fischer moved his family into the
upper floors in his law firm onto the
lower floors
but the state department then found out
about this they insisted epstein had not
gotten permission to sublet and besides
it was furious about the profit that he
was pocketing
and so the feds made epstein kick this
guy out
why didn't we know about this
why did we've been talking about jeffrey
epstein
for years now
and for a while the mainstream media
didn't want to pick it up and for a
while the government didn't want to talk
about him there was always some sketchy
stuff about him why are we only finding
out right now in the year of our lord
2022
years after jeffrey epstein
killed himself long after the trial of
elaine maxwell his madam was taking
place
long after all this die all these dodgy
crimes were taking place long after alex
acosta the u.s attorney was apparently
told that jeffrey epstein belongs to
intelligence and then that story went
away
now we find out that jeffrey epstein's
landlord in his infamous new york city
mance the landlord was the u.s state
department
huh
what
can we get an answer on that
can we get an answer from anybody i
don't have any i don't have any point to
make here just raising the question
thought that was a little bit curious
seems to me a lot of people have
suggested maybe jeffrey epstein wasn't
just acting on his own maybe jeffrey
epstein wasn't just this eccentric
gazillionaire with some weird sexual
perversions maybe jeffrey epstein had
the backing of state actors and whenever
anyone brings up that question
all of a sudden the story goes away
maybe maybe jeffrey epstein didn't kill
himself maybe there's a lot more to this
story that implicates a lot more people
maybe
after years of these investigations and
everyone doing their due diligence and
oh good guillaine maxwell's going to
prison even though she's now being moved
to a much lower security facility in
florida that's kind of interesting how
come we still don't have the black book
how come we still don't know a damn
thing about jeffrey epstein and his
operations and the people he entrapped
and the
got it in writing right here got it in
print the state actors that he was
regularly working with so
it's just more evidence
what we've all known for a long time
which is that there is a degree of
corruption
in the permanent bureaucracy that a lot
of us did not know existed i'm not just
talking about all those politicians are
corrupt yes politicians are very often
corrupt yes political systems tend to be
corrupt but i'm talking about
not the elected people exactly i'm
talking about the permanent bureaucracy
the state department the executive
agencies the intelligence community
that
has
and the media that totally carries water
for them
that
has been operating without virtually any
oversight for a very very long time
implicated in some very serious crimes
and we're not getting we're not getting
any real news reports we're getting how
come how come the head of the blaze just
poking through some random threads on
the internet
stumbled across this why didn't the
washington post cover this why didn't
the new york times but the new york
daily news that's where this was
reported in the first place how come we
didn't hear about this for many of the
big establishment corporate media
organizations what are they
covering up
this is the kind of issue
that gives us
trump 2024 okay this is the kind of
issue that gave us trump 2016
and trump 2020 and that is going to be
very powerful for trump in 2024 because
the thing that trump had and i think to
a large degree still has that no other
candidate
did have
is that he is
totally from outside this world
whatever you want to say about trump and
his vices and his bad habits
the guy is not a career politician he's
not the usual kind of politician that
you see from either party
and whatever you want to say about trump
the permanent bureaucracy the deep state
the intelligence community whatever
hates this guy's guts and acted i think
quite clearly illegally to undermine his
campaign to spy on him and to undermine
his presidency which when you look at
the degree of corruption from the
permanent bureaucracy
makes any reasonable person like trump
more and so he's out campaigning trump
is very much on the campaign trail again
even though he has not announced a
presidential run
he's out there he's speaking most
recently in washington dc about the
issues that are going to affect 2024
the society that refuses to protect its
children
is a society that soon will
not be able to protect anybody
this is a hallmark of cultural and
social decay
against which we should fight back very
hard and very soon we don't have time to
wait years to do this
the sickos who are pushing sexual
content in kindergartens
or providing
puberty blockers to young children who
have no idea what a puberty blocker is
neither do i by the way
neither do most of the people in the
audience as you smile
let's just say they're not good
are not just
engaged in acts of depravity in many
cases they are breaking the law
and they should be held fully
accountable
now
this is something that trump does that
other politicians don't do every
politician reads from the teleprompter
just about and trump is reading from the
teleprompter there and he doesn't quite
have that 2016 energy it's early in the
cycle he's a little bit older it's not
he's not at a rally or something like
that so it's a little bit and he's just
reading from the prompter about the
puberty blockers and a lot of people
don't know what they are and then he
breaks the fourth wall and he says yeah
i don't really know what they are either
isn't this stuff weird
and he gives you this sense that he is
actually a spectator in the political
process that he's kind of with you he's
on he's on the same side of the stage
that you are he goes what the hell are
these people doing i don't know but it's
bad we know it's bad right we all know
that it's bad so that's going to be his
pitch it
if this is the campaign it's good that
he's talking about these social issues
the the issues like transiting the kids
have proven very effective for
republicans recently
but it's not
it's not that 2016 energy everybody's
talking about transiting the kids
trump knee if trump is going to really
come out like a wrecking ball like he
did in 2016 he's going to need something
that
distinguishes him from the other guys
because everyone's going to be talking
about transiting the kids in 2016 it was
we're going to build a big beautiful
wall we're going to completely shut down
illegal immigration all these illegals
are rapists and murderers and nobody was
talking like that on the republican
stage i don't care how against illegal
immigration you were you weren't talking
like trump trump needs something to
distinguish him
again because the even the outsider
angle is going to be less persuasive
after the man was president for four
years i still think there's a good
argument to be made but it's not going
to be as strong so we it as we approach
the midterms as we get after the
midterms as we see to approach the
moment where donald trump might be
announcing that he's running
whoever is advising him is going to need
to hone that campaign message to give
people a reason to vote for him
over say a ron desantis who right now is
way behind in the polls but it's also
because his name recognition is is much
much lower compared to trump
ron desantis obviously wants to
challenge
president trump in 2024
and desantis has some real advantages
here he's got some trump has some real
advantages he's super famous he's
hilarious he's a celebrity he was
already the president he's got a lot of
support he's got a lot of advantages
desantis has some advantages too though
desantis is young
he's new
and
novelty can be very helpful in politics
and he is full of energy he is also
saying all the right things
we are taking a stand and these bills
i'm signing into law today foreign
adversaries will not have access to our
schools government and companies like
they have in the past in fact the first
bill that i signed today safeguards our
public institutions from undo florence
foreign influence and that means
prohibiting agreements uh between public
entities and the communist party of
china or cuba or any of these other
malignant forces as of the time we sign
this bill and it goes into effect
florida we will be banning things like
confucius institutions from being in our
universities or in our colleges and i
know we had issues with that right here
in in miami-dade counties we're also
going to sign the combating corporate
espionage in florida act it creates new
criminal offenses in florida for the
theft and trafficking of trade secrets
[Applause]
this is really good stuff the policy is
really good we do need to kick out this
foreign influence especially chinese
influence
something that desantis is
honing in on which is something that
trump really honed in on which is
something that scandalized virtually
every other republican
in 2016 and almost all the republicans
at the national level is
they realize that we need to wield state
power
we don't need to become tyrannical we
don't need to become dictators we don't
need to wield state power capriciously
or arbitrarily but conservatives when we
get power we need to use it justly we
need to use the power that the people
give us to do good things and improve
people's lives for a long time for
decades
in the conservative movement
republican politicians have have
repeated libertarian slogans
to avoid doing their jobs
i said well you know if we r gosh if we
regulate google we'll be just like the
leftists oh we can't do they would be
very wrong to wield the state to stop
drag queen perverts from jiggling for
little kids oh no we can't that would
make us no different from the leftists
if we ever used any government power at
all no no the founding fathers hated the
idea of law and order and justice no
what are you talking about that's just
completely made up it's it's a political
joke it's a farce that was pushed by
largely by big corporations that just
wanted less regulation and it was pushed
by uh libertarians who
as a percentage of the electorate are a
very very small percentage and who who
have an outsized influence or have had
an outside influence in the conservative
movement but don't actually represent a
large portion of the american voting
base and it it represents an idea
that actually does not have a lot of
grounding in american history
and it represents an idea that
politically is just completely
impractical
power is going to flow to the people who
are willing to use it and the
institutions that are willing to use it
that's a basic law of politics and so if
the republicans get elected and say
elect me i'm not going to do anything
then you're just seating the entire
culture to the left and then i have to
ask why am i even voting for you
why would i vote for the republican he
does nothing i vote for the democrat he
does something but i vote for the
republican and the democrats going to do
something anyway so what's the
difference there's no reason and what
desantis and what trump and some other
people too you're seeing a little bit in
the senate from senator cruz from uh
josh hawley a little bit you're seeing
this movement among conservatives now to
say wait no we we can keep boys out of
the girls room we can ban drag queen
story hour we can shut down certain
chinese goods i know maybe it'll hurt
gdp a little bit but this is a national
security threat now we can keep chinese
communist influence out of our schools
we can say no we can wield the power
justly the founding fathers were very
well aware of that every sane person in
our country was aware of that
until very very recently this is a
related story on this
some big porn website just just went
down a porn operator just pled guilty to
sex trafficking to a sex trafficking
conspiracy in a san diego federal court
i'm not going to say the name of the
porn company but their modus operandi
was that they would lure these girls in
these girls who wanted money who were 18
years old 19 years old and they would
say hey come do this porn shoot and
don't worry it's not going to end up on
the internet it's going to be for a
private dvd collection overseas that's
never going to be an american will give
you some money and they'd bring the
girls in and they'd give them booze and
they'd give them drugs and they'd
pressure them and they'd coerce them in
some cases and then the girls would do
it in one case the girl was underage
there was a girl that was i think 17.
and then what happens
the videos end up online ruins the girls
lives ruins the girls reputations and
they've had all these problems since
then and this this porn company just
went down the guy who owns the porn
company is a fugitive from justice right
now he's on the run they haven't caught
him yet this is great stuff
the website's not great stuff but using
state power to shut this down is great
stuff
it's really important to do this one
it's important for the girls you might
say what what these girls these girls
are so stupid they didn't realize it was
going to end up on the internet
yeah i'm not saying these girls
acted in the wisest manner i'm not
saying no but
we should protect we should protect
naive
reckless 18 year old girls from
ruining their lives because of these
predators who lie to them and deceive
them and drug them and have sex with
them on camera and make a buck doing it
it's just wrong there is no right to
pornography pornography is not good for
you
okay it's not something that we well you
know george washington and john adams
they patrick henry said give me high
speed internet porn or give me death
right is that what he said i don't think
so no this stuff was considered illegal
universally it was considered ugly and
something that should be suppressed
until about 10 or 20 years ago
and here here's why by the way
here's the reason that even if you like
porn or whatever if you're listening to
the show you probably don't think porn
is the greatest thing in the world but
even if you say well people should have
a right people should have the license
at least to look at porn sometimes
here's why porn is a bad thing and
here's why young men write into my show
constantly about how much they hate porn
and how it's ruining their lives because
they're addicted to it
ask yourself
why is it bad for a kid to grow up in a
bad neighborhood you know we all agree
it's bad when kids grow up in a bad
neighborhood it's bad for them we'll say
oh man those kids in the inner city man
they never had a chance there's gangs
around there's drugs education is
terrible they grew up in a bad neighbor
it's not even their fault but it's going
to put them on a bad path they're much
more likely to have a bad outcome if
they grow up in a bad neighborhood why
is that
because
our environment matters our society
matters it affects us even things that
the kids are not doing just being around
that stuff in your society does affect
you and it and it can make your life
worse that's that's just called politics
that's just called living together
it's when you live in a culture mired in
crime and vice and sin when you're when
you're living in a place like portland
and you've got just this stuff all
around you you're not the one taking the
meth you're not the one defecating in
public but it's just all around you it
affects your life and it makes things
worse and it and it tempts you to do the
drugs and attempts to get involved in
the crimes and it tempts you to get
involved in all sorts of bad stuff and
we have a political right to say no get
off my lawn
a classic conservative slogan get off my
lawn get off my lawn now we have a right
to say no you don't you don't get to
take advantage of the girls
you don't get to deceive the
the naive 18 year old girls no you don't
get to do the drugs no you don't you
don't get you don't get to do this stuff
okay we want
good neighborhoods a nice place to live
you want people to conserve stuff you
got to give people a nice lovable place
to live we have the right to a nice life
to a flourishing place we have a right
to not just to liberty properly
understood which is not the same thing
as license
we have a right to the blessings of
liberty
the liberty used as an instrument to
virtue into a flourishing society that's
what the founding fathers thought that's
what sane people thought and that's what
the the
dirt bags were trying to degrade our
culture want us all to forget don't
forget it you know we just hit another
historic
milestone in our company's history no
i'm not talking about us closing in on 1
million daily wire plus subscribers or
selling over 70 000 jeremy's razors or
even me hitting 1 million subscribers on
youtube thanks to you i am referring to
matt's movie what is a woman
finally getting
like one critic review
so you know the critics the people loved
it i mean the movie had almost 100
popularity you know audience review but
the critics didn't want to touch it on
rotten tomatoes so then
we got
i think i think the number is five
critics
watched the movie
and they loved it so it's now got the
movie has
a 100 critics review on rotten tomatoes
this is really the the libs stepping on
a rake this is really the libs
undermining themselves because when the
the liberal critics boycotted the movie
it just left it open for
moderate to conservative critics all of
whom love the movie because it's a great
movie so go see what the critics are
raving about with a hundred percent
approval go to daily wire plus become a
member stream what is a woman get 35 off
your membership when you sign up today
dailywireplus.com
we have now arrived at my favorite time
of the week when i get to hear from you
in the voice mailbag
voicemail bag is brought to you by
puretalk go to puretalk.com select a
plan enter promo code noel's podcast
save 50 off your first month all right
let's get to the first question
hey michael this is camille i'm just
calling in because i have a question
about guys and girls mentality with
dating
so as a girl i have a very intense moral
hangover probably derived from a lot of
catholic guilt but it kind of prevented
me from engaging in my quote-unquote
whole years but i was wondering if guys
have that same type of guilt
if they're in their player years not
just guilt for
what they're doing to girls if they're
not
dating them if they're just hooking up
with them but if they have any guilt of
just kind of living that more immoral
lifestyle of hookup culture
we'd love to hear your thoughts thanks
and love the show
love those phrases that i i realized i
did hear correctly when you said the men
have the player years and then i think
the first phrase you used was hoe years
for women so first thing
generally if you haven't already gone
through it probably good to avoid those
years
i know it's very easy i think a lot of
people fall into it obviously but you
know if you can avoid i wouldn't i
wouldn't aim
at having hoe years or player years
probably not that great your question
though do you do men
feel some shame and guilt from that the
answer is yes
yeah
not just because you roll over on the
pillow and you look at the girl lying
next to you and you say oh why am i yes
why am i doing this not just because of
the girl
but because of you because you are
degrading yourself
because you are
when you pursue
women or men in that way
is just a vessel for your own pleasure
you are degrading yourself to the level
of an animal
you are a human being with intellect
with reason with virtue with integrity
with worth but you degrade yourself to
the level of an animal that just needs
to
be titillated when you do that kind of
thing and it reduces your view of the
other person too you're degrading the
other person and even if you have a
crush on the other person even if you
think very highly of the other person
when you engage in an act together that
is intrinsically shameful that will that
will lower your view of the other person
as well and it will diminish the
possibilities for a longer kind of love
affair with that person so yeah men have
it too
women men and women have it a little bit
differently because men and women
approach sex differently but men have it
too and men can get sex-osted and men
can feel that same kind of shame and
ideally that would be sooner rather than
later if they have to go through that at
all next question
howdy nostradamus my name is houston and
my question is about a topic that has
come up when discussing religion among
my peers
i've grown closer to the church while in
college both thanks to you and my study
group here's the thing i listen to a lot
of metal but not just any type
specifically death metal
i understand that some of the lyrics are
blasphemous but i'm far more captivated
by the intricacies of the instruments
which makes sense since i play guitar
myself both for a band and a church
is it possible to be a practicing
christian while also enjoying and
performing this type of music
if not couldn't the same be said for the
modern degeneracy that kids are
listening to now i've been told that as
long as i don't feel conviction i'm okay
would love to hear your thoughts on this
thanks a sworthy breakfast taco
really really good question and i'm
going to give you a really really hard
answer
yeah you probably shouldn't listen to
that
you sh i'm sorry i don't want to be a
wet blanket it's not even just the
lyrics i mean obviously you shouldn't
listen to music that is blasphemous but
you can find metal you can find
extremely hardcore metal that is not
overtly blasphemous that's not even the
main issue
the main issue with
death metal is the is the music actually
it's more the percussion plato has this
point which is he
he observes that
more than anything else it's music and
rhythm even especially that
that can transform your soul
in that it bypasses your reason when
you're listening to music especially
music that's very percussive especially
music that's very
uh bee boppy you know or in the case of
death metal you know it's all just like
when
when you listen to that you're not
reasoning about it you're not sitting
back like you're listening to i don't
know a symphony by bach and thinking
about it and thinking in a in a really
calm way about it
and and even then you know
even more classical music will bypass
your reason to a large degree but when
you're listening to very percussive
stuff it will totally bypass your reason
and it will transform your soul it will
take the strongest hold upon your soul
as plato says and so you've got to be
aware of that
i'm not saying you can never listen to
death metal again but
but i wouldn't recommend it
i wouldn't recommend it i would
recommend
i would recommend generally avoiding
things
that take you totally out of your reason
and when you're in a mosh pit just or
you're listening to death metal or
something like that you are out of your
reason when you drink
three bottles of whiskey you're going to
be out of your reason too and you don't
you don't
want to do that sorry to be a wet
blanket not saying you have to totally
tune out all the death metal immediately
but i think as you
as you grow in your spiritual life you
you will naturally
uh pull away from that kind of music and
pursue other kinds of tastes sorry sorry
to say i'm sorry
to rain on your parade but that's just
the way it is i'm sorry that i have to
plato pill you but that's the way it
goes next question
hello michael this is tony fauci
i wanted to call and let you know that i
am deeply disappointed in the
disinformation that you've been
spreading on your show
and i wanted to tell you to tell all of
your sheep to wear the mask
your sheep need to wear the mask my
question is this do you really think
elon musk is going to buy twitter
if so
i might just have to retire early
thanks and remember to wear the donut
michael just wear the donut
you're not the real tony fauci i'm the
tony foggy no you're the tony fudgy
which one do i which one do i go for i
don't i know that was an excellent
it was a really excellent dr fauci
impression or you just are tony fauci to
your question
is elon musk gonna buy twitter right now
it looks like he is not i actually did
have a friend of mine who from the very
beginning of the elon twitter
saga said elon doesn't really want to
buy twitter he just wants an excuse to
sell tesla stock at all-time highs it's
the same thing as when
elizabeth warren complained that he
didn't pay enough taxes and elon did a
twitter poll where he said he was going
to sell a bunch of tesla and then he
would have to pay taxes on it my friend
viewed that as another kind of ruse just
to be able to sell tesla at very high
prices uh so it could be that
uh it also the other option is this
could be a way for elon musk to try to
get a better deal on twitter but i don't
know if i were a gambling man today i
would say elon does not buy twitter and
it was all just a really funny troll
which is fine by me i really enjoyed the
troll i got a real kick out of it and if
elon got to make a little bit of money
on it all the better though it may
backfire he may end up having to spend a
lot of money uh to get out of the
twitter deal all of that remains to be
seen but either way we all got a bunch
of laws out of it so i think it was
worthwhile next voicemail back question
mr nostradamus i am smiling sam uh i am
a blue check mart athlete i've been in
the ufc for a number of years i and i'm
one of those guys that thinks lebron and
people like that should shut up and
dribble
so i've kind of held myself to that same
principle i will shut up and punch
now my question for you is
should i keep doing that i have a topic
that i won't i will not hold my tongue
on abortion i am a foster parent i have
six children i have adopted one and i'm
going to continue adopting children
until they are all mine
and they are all very loved
other than that though i tend to keep my
mouth shut because like i said earlier
i'm a big fan of the shut up and dribble
thing
they aren't
should i be fighting fire with fire
should i be using all the power that
comes with my little blue check mark to
try and fight back to try and reassure
others that i'm with them or should i
not
i appreciate it also i live in nashville
i would love to have you and your family
out for uh barbecue one of these days
anyways keep up the good work my friend
and thank you for the advice that sounds
great thank you for the invitation would
love to do it and thank you for the
question very good question
should you use the great power and
responsibility of the blue check and
voice your opinions
perhaps
to some degree
my advice here is it's not an all or
nothing kind of thing
you don't need to either keep your mouth
totally shut or
have the maga hat on doing jumping jacks
constantly you're very lucky that you're
in the ufc which is probably the most
conservative sports league there is in
the country right now so you'll get a
little grace for that anyway
but as you say i won't keep my mouth
shut on abortion you could
be judicious and prudent about the ways
that you speak up you're not a
politician you're not hold you don't
hold a public office so you don't have
to speak up on lots of these different
issues you certainly can but perhaps you
pick your battles perhaps you do it in a
way that's a little
subtler you know you do it through
retweets you do it through posting hey i
listen to this i really liked this you
do this through weighing in in a way
that maybe has a little bit of a lighter
touch you're very
known for a tougher touch
in ufc so maybe you try a little bit of
a lighter touch in politics i think that
can be really
charming and effective if you're a
little bit winsome and witty about these
things so i i would
i would maybe lean into that it doesn't
have to be an all or nothing owning the
libs is much more an art than a science
great question all right let's get to at
least one regular mail bag before we go
from jackson
hey michael first off just want to say i
love the show
and have listened to you for years thank
you very much recently the topic of
sexual morality and ethics has come up a
lot with particular emphasis on the
perils of promiscuous and hedonistic sex
outside the confines of a monogamous
union yes we are living in the age of
monkey pox keeps cropping up a key
recurring point raised is that the kinds
of sexual activities that typically
occur in these environments are deviant
in nature driven by a failing a falling
of society's morality and commitment to
prioritize healthy monogamous
relationships my question to you is this
if a man and a woman are in a monogamous
and committed marriage to one another is
it okay for them to engage in sexual
acts that may be considered kinky
or would that still be considered
succumbing to the same temptations that
drive so many to make immoral decisions
about their sexual behaviors curious
about your perspective thanks again for
the fantastic show really good question
the question is
you you've got some kind of pervy
desires
is it okay to
to act on them
no
basically is the short answer
no it's not because they are by
definition perverted they're distorted
they're disordered they're corrupted and
you don't want to be those things
you don't want to be
corrupted you want to be properly
ordered think about what is the most
popular
kinky
behavior in our pop culture
it's it's 50 shades of grey right it's
it's bdsm
what what does bdsm stand for it stands
for bondage
dominance
sadism
and masochism
those are all bad things because they're
all wrong separately and torturing
yourself torturing other people
dominating someone you're tyranizing
someone and enslaving someone those are
all
bad things so you wouldn't want to do
that you certainly wouldn't want to do
that to your wife
now you might say well i'm not really
doing it it's not real it's just pretend
but you are really doing it that's the
thing it's not even just a fantasy in
your mind you are really acting it out
in real time on a real human being and
you can even both pretend that you're
not really doing it but you are and
where this is
sort of dangerous for you is that
your desires influence your behaviors
right you're saying i have this sexual
perverted desire and i therefore want to
behave in a way that that expresses that
but your behaviors also affect your
desires this is what an acquired taste
is when you're a little kid you don't
like beer you know you take a sip of
your daddy's beer you don't like it when
you get older you have some more beer
and then you start to like it and you
acquire that taste and then you start to
desire beer your behavior anyone who's
ever engaged well with drugs it's very
clear or really just any kind of habit
you know that the more you do it the
more you can acquire a desire for it and
so the more you indulge these kinds of
desires
the the more
powerful the desire will become and the
desire in fact could even change and
become more intense and more hardcore it
happens with drugs it happens with sex
and porn it happens with
sloth it happens with all kinds of vices
and so you don't want to do that a good
image of this actually comes from dante
where
dante has this erotic love for his lover
beatrice not a lover they don't act on
anything but she's just the woman in his
mind and the beauty of beatrice uh is is
erotic for him that it arouses erotic
feelings and he doesn't just repress it
i'm not saying just repress everything
he
points it in the right direction so the
his erotic love for beatrice leads him
up to heaven to see god he sees god
literally reflected in her eyes he's
looking at his lover's eyes and those
eyes are reflecting the love of god
now had dante not been ordering his
erotic love in the right way in the
right direction if instead he had been
dreaming about or fantasizing about you
know
taking beatrice to 50 shades of grey and
whipping her with chains and things like
that then he probably would not be
pursuing that all the way up to heaven
he'd probably be going in the other
direction
where the where the whips and chains are
used really all of the time i
this is a real wet blanket kind of a
mailbag in a way cause i'm saying don't
listen to death metal or it's not good
for you don't do weird stuff with your
wife don't
but
it is
it's a fact okay and as our pal says
facts don't care about your feelings all
right that's the way it goes wise people
have known this throughout all of
history and it's it's not just giving
something up it's not just giving up the
death metal it's not just giving up the
weird
whips and chains stuff that you want to
do with your wife it's
it's giving you a much better
alternative it's pointing you at
something which is higher which is music
that can be higher that can be just as
or more so instrumentally intricate and
complicated and beautiful much more even
than the popular music you're listening
to and and an understanding of love and
even erotic desire that is much higher
than whatever kind of
behavior which you already admit is
perverted might be
in your mind at the moment we're falling
creatures so we're going to fall short
but you actually can
you can order yourself
in a way you can improve you can grow in
virtue your desires can become ordered
in a more correct way and you can
more and more approach the love that's
that moves the sun and the other stars
tune in tonight by the way to catch an
all new episode of daily wire backstage
where your favorite daily wire hosts
come together to discuss the news of the
day you will join me ben matt drew and
the guide king jeremy boring at 7 pm
eastern on the daily waters youtube
channel or at
dailywireplus.com it's going to be a lot
of fun until then i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show see you
next time
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor-in-chief and co-host of
morningwire on today's episode new
evidence suggests a landmark alzheimer's
study may have been fraudulent a senate
report details how china has attempted
to infiltrate the fed and house
democrats move to impose term limits on
the supreme court
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire